[Musique]
par un matin de décembre
les participants arrivent au hec pour
leur tout premier cours à l'école des
dirigeants des premières nations
ils sont 17 des élus et des
administrateurs d'organisations
autochtones provenant des quatre coins
du québec
parmi eux suzanne bacon charland le
vice-chef du conseil des innus de
pessamit tu sur la côte nord moi je suis
très fébrile je suis enthousiaste très
tôt le matin comme ça c'est rare mais
je suis prête moi j'adore le logo qui
est à canon je m'embarque dans quelque
chose en aillant l'école du dirigeant va
pouvoir avoir connais des gens vont
pouvoir poser nos questions on voit
souty il y à aussi adam jourdain unis
nous qui directeur général adjoint du
conseil des atikamekw de wemotaci en
haute mauricie
déjà détenteur d'un baccalauréat en
administration des affaires il gère
plusieurs sociétés en commandite
plusieurs soirs à forer story on en un
comptoir alimentaire aussi on ne s'en
servait son nom pourvoirie
pas qu'on en a plusieurs dans une série
aussi que sans rien faire on commence à
s'exporter au niveau économique au monde
il espère que la formation lui permettra
de devenir un meilleur gestionnaire pour
en faire bénéficier sa communauté ça
nous permet de nous rassembler tous de
voir des problèmatiques puis de voir
peut-être des solutions qu'on n'aurait
pas vu son arrêté de
[Musique]
l'école des dirigeants des premières
nations est une idée de manon jeannotte
unique mac et de ken rock unis nous
d'eux ancien diplômé d hec ils ont tous
deux fait le même constat les formations
universitaires sont rarement adapté à la
réalité autochtone jusqu'à rapport aux
premières nations c'est quand même là le
heureusement la loi sur les indiens
c'est pas les mêmes structures c'est pas
les mêmes lois c'est très très différent
il faut toujours
savoir comment on va appliquer ce chez
nous tandis que l'eau mais on fait on le
coq répit c'est vraiment à partir de
comment ça se passe chez nous ken rock
et elles sont donc allés cogner à la
porte des hec qui a déjà une école du
dirigeant depuis plus de 65 à
l'établissement a tout de suite accepté
d'épauler ses deux anciens étudiants
pour créer une école dédiée aux
autochtones on est là pour donner des
ressources données l'envol et dans ce
cadre là le choix l'ambition dans
quelques années ces deux peut-être
construire un première nation inc mais à
l'image à l'image et selon les valeurs
des premières nations au bout de quatre
modules de trois jours en présentiel et
en virtuel des participants pourront
obtenir une certification
tous les cours sont donnés en cours
enseignement par un formateur autochtone
et un enseignant d hec celle que les
manques la vision qu'ont heureusement
vision traditionnelle puis le 2e rei de
la vision académique hec cyprès missilou
et des fois mon travail en sang le
premier module porte sur le leadership
authentique on traite notamment de
l'intelligence émotionnelle un des
formateurs invités pour l'occasion et
nul autre que ghislain picard le chef de
l'assemblée des premières nations on
nous demande alors de quitter la salle
pour favoriser un partage sans venu on a
été plus je pourrais être dans l'émotion
puis dans nos façons de voir nos chances
aussi en tant que communauté nos
aspirations n'aura je recevrai
m'intéressant je pense one et tout animé
par ce même c'est même sentiment de
vouloir aider notre peuple à 101
grandira à s'épanouir ce que j'ai vu ce
matin l'eau des personnes qui se sent
bien dans les responsabilités qu'ils ont
eu l on a assumé et qui ont l'impression
que qui peuvent contribuer davantage
pour moins la démarche est aussi pour
aller chercher alain storrer restaurer
cette confiance la halle estime la
dignité et près de bâle alors qu'ils ont
été écorchés l'eau depuis les 150
dernières années
fin mars c'est dans la communauté
huronne wendat de wendat qui donnait le
quatrième et dernier module du programme
en fait on vous invite à aller
sur cela pour mettre un mot qui selon
vous définissez quoi une bonne
gouvernance le cours auquel nous
assistons porte sur la gouvernance
les participants échangent avec le
groupe et les formateurs souvent les
théories éducatives qu'on reçoit
universitario ma communauté c'est
vraiment un complexe haut et je rêve du
jour où a affirmé ce droit doit de
toujours pouvoir créer nos propres
structures qui vont davantage coller à
la réalité alors que l' aventure tire à
sa fin adam estime que l'expérience a
été bénéfique il a notamment apprécié le
coup enseignements de croo robbins des
professeurs là avec des gens qui
connaissent la réalité si on voit des
choses on voit des situations vraiment
que communaux comme une autre parce que
je pense que la formule est excellente
on a eu des grosses réflexion on essaie
de ramener ça dans nos communautés je
pense que c'est ça qui est fantastique
début mai de retour ou hec pour la
cérémonie de remise des certifications
[Applaudissements]
susan et adam c'est le moment de voir
ses efforts récompensés
7 si moche la fierté que j'ai envers
travers tout le programme en vrai je
suis fier moi en tant que personne et en
tant qu individuellement mais fier de
tout rond et la formation donne déjà des
résultats tangibles j'ai des gens
portent certains changements l'on parle
d'un comité d'innovation à wemotaci on
parle également de nouvelles façons de
procéder dans des conseils
d'administration
l'école des dirigeants des premières
nations a de grandes ambitions
les programmes pour les gestionnaires et
des entrepreneurs seront lancés au cours
des prochains mois on a pour objectif de
former 1000 étudiants au cours des cinq
prochaines années
là